[Music]
babe look at who we have bring in
reinforcements yeah this week is huge
okay it's go big or go home I decided to
bring in none other than Argentine
specialist Maksim Chmerkovskiy mango
it's action is our genre so we need like
some action-packed moves we need to
fight between us we're two spies I'm the
bad spy he's the woods bye
so I'm kind of like the director this
movie today right yes whatever you want
max let's see what we have and then roll
up a benefit of Max coming in today he's
been gracious with his time and teaching
me some of his max ways being max is a
lifestyle and I think I can pick up a
few things from max there he goes it's
interesting having a guy he dances
different than a woman max obviously is
teaching me from his point of view as a
man who knows how to dance and while
pita is a fantastic dancer it is kind of
helpful sometimes to show like the guys
intentions and kind of the things that
max thinks about so it's very helpful to
have him here and show me a finger -
yeah this is
to one of us in this house we're win
this rematch it's all about Solan thank
you very much oh very helpful mwah good
job
[Music]